(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring the question
what makes someone creepy?
- Ooh.
- And other questions
that we received from you Mythical Beasts.
- Yeah there's lots of
thought-provoking questions.
I'm conjuring thoughts.
Wasn't easy.
- Hmm.
- I'm having trouble conjuring
thoughts at this moment,
just fair warning--
- Don't say conjuring
because it makes me think
of the movie Conjuring
and I just was talking
about it with someone
last night and I don't
like to think about it.
- Then why were you talking
to somebody about it?
- I love to talk about it.
- You do.
- I just don't like to think about it.
- Okay.
We're gonna get into the world of creepy
and some other things.
Including if we had a
triathlon of dad sports,
what would they be and who would win?
I got some thoughts on
that and other stuff too.
- But first I wanted to check in with you.
I've noticed something that's happened
a couple times I've
been visiting your home.
- Oh yeah?
- You have nonchalantly said,
"Okay Google, dim the
lights in the living room."
(chuckles)
Or something along those lines
and they've actually dimmed.
Or they, you've spoken to your home.
- Uh-huh.
- And I know this is not--
- That's right,
we have a--
- This is not a new thing.
- I have an intimate
relationship with my home.
- And I'm in the process
of going full bore.
- Well yeah all morning
I was looking over at you
at your desk, just kinda seeing
what you were working on.
It seems like you were deep--
- It wasn't all morning.
- You were deep into
figuring out how to talk to your house.
- Yeah.
- I think you even Googled,
I looked over at one
point and you were like,
how can I be as cool as Link?
- Yeah, it's interesting when
you Google that directly.
- Have you done that?
What pops up?
- A wikiHow.
- Which I wrote.
(both chuckle)
So you wanna talk to your lights too.
- Yeah.
- I talk to my lights.
- Well interesting thing, so I was talking
to Daniel, who is the
reason that we look so cool
on the internet.
I mean actually yeah, it's Mike Feldman.
He's the one that makes us
look so cool in the merch,
but Daniel does--
- It was not merch.
- He'll go out and get some
clothes for us sometimes
to wear on the show and he was in,
I was talking to him about
I kind of had been looking, what smart,
you gotta get the smart bulbs.
You gotta get the bulbs
that can be spoken to
or basically they register with your,
well you can do the bulbs,
you can do the things
that you plug in but you
also have to do the switches.
And the reason I wanted
to do the bulbs themselves
and not just the, I know
what you got is a converter
you plug into and then it
can control on and off or--
- Yeah you plug it into the wall,
then you plug the lamp into the thing
which I incidentally,
I got a couple of those
from a GMM episode,
I think it's where we
were remote controlling
Christmas lights or
something and I was like hey,
when we're done with that
I wanna take that home
and I hooked it up and
then I just ended up
getting more of 'em.
And I did get one that was hard-wired
to my front porch lights so that I could
speak to my home--
- Did you have an electrician
do that or you did that?
- Yeah, no, I don't do electrical.
- Okay.
- I can't use a knife.
I can't use fire, I can't use electrics.
- Yeah 'cause I'm gonna have to get,
again, I want to be able to
control the front lights,
the lights, right now
they're on like a timer
but I'd like to be able
to control the lights
that are on the house,
the lights at the driveway
and then all lights.
But you also gotta get,
anything that's like an
overhead light that's like,
we have recessed lighting in most rooms
and that's on a switch so
now you gotta get the switch
that can be controlled.
- You wanna talk to every
single light in your house?
- All lights.
- That's too much.
- Well I'll be the
judge of that once I can
talk to everything.
- You're going overboard.
You're going overboard.
- Well you know why I'm
going overboard, because
when I was talking--
- To be like me.
- To Daniel,
no, because no, see, you gave me an idea
of what it could be like to be cool.
- Okay.
- But you actually aren't.
- You're not as cool
as I'm gonna be when I can literally speak
to every light source in my entire house.
And let me tell you what.
- That's too much.
- Here's what Daniel
told me about, he said, I've
got a friend who did this
to their house and the reason you need
the smart bulbs and not
just the little converter
is because these bulbs can be programmed
to change color and flash and do all kinds
of things based on voice commands,
and this guy has created a custom program
for his different friends.
And so he's like hey, Google.
Sandra's here and all of a sudden,
it'll flash red and it'll play like
♪ Dun dun dun ♪
Google Home will access a track.
- Connects to its Spotify playlist first.
- So you think you're cool now,
you wait until you come
to my house and I say,
"Okay Google, Link's here."
And just see how cool you feel then.
- Well if you get the right camera,
your house will know that I'm there.
- I'm also doing that.
- And then you don't even
have to say okay Google,
Link's here which is an odd thing to say.
- Aw you think you can
program an intelligent camera
to recognize your face and
then play a specific track,
I'm sure you can.
- No.
- No yeah because--
- There's a missing connection.
- No there's not because things have the--
- You're gonna basically
rewire your entire house
so that when Sandra comes
over it can flash red?
- Yeah, exactly.
(Link scoffs)
- That's nutty, man.
I mean that's novel.
But you'll never do it.
- Interestingly,
I'm actually surprised because
you know the reason I'm compelled
to do every single light
is because it just seems clean,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah but--
- In fact,
just having a couple of
lights you can control,
but then oh I gotta get up
and touch the light switch
for that one, Sandra.
- The lights that I control are the ones
that I never walk past the switch.
Or--
- I don't wanna walk at all.
I wanna roll around like a--
- Or the ones that I want--
- Like a slug and--
- To be on a timer.
- Just speak to my house.
- I mean I'm just saying
it's not gonna be worth it.
You wanna be in bed and say okay Google,
turn off all the lights.
- Well I haven't gotten there
but that's another great idea.
- See that would be useful.
- But not with Sandra.
- I have my different lights
that turn on all the lights.
There's certain lights
that I want to turn on
with the sunset, that
happens automatically
and then they turn off at different times.
- Well you can also set routines.
- The nook light turns off at like nine.
The chair light, I got a
nook light, a chair light,
a couch light, a front
light, and a back light.
And that's all the lights I got.
- Well I'm gonna have 47.
- All the other ones
I use a switch.
- Yeah so archaic, you have to touch it.
- For every light--
- Gross.
- Rhett, for every light
you have to name it.
You're gonna have to name 47 lights
and then you're gonna have
to remember those names.
- And I'm gonna do cool
names like Battleship,
light B12.
- Yeah you're gonna have
to come up with a system.
- And I'm gonna be the only
one who understands it.
- Right and then you'll be--
- You gotta talk to Dad
if you want a light adjusted.
- You'll be included with
everyone who never uses it.
- So it'd be like, okay
Dad, turn on light B12
and I'll be like, okay
Google, turn on light B12.
- I mean--
- Well no they won't
say B12, they'll say porch
light, and I'll say C17.
- I'm just telling you man.
I'm exposing it.
I'm looking out for you.
You don't, I mean I'm
basically at my limit
of the number of light,
I can't remember now.
- You just told me all of 'em in the span
of a minute.
- But sometimes I'm like okay Google,
turn on the (stutters) couch light
and it's like I'm sorry, I
haven't learned that yet.
It's like it's very polite.
(Rhett laughs)
- Well that's just--
- It takes the onus--
- That's user error.
You know another thing--
- It's tough to
keep 'em straight, man,
you're gonna have problems.
- Here's the thing,
you can get your lights
to be tied into your intelligent cameras.
And so that if you
happen to be out of town
and someone comes to your front door,
if the intelligent doorbell with a camera
senses someone at the door, it can turn,
it can be a program between
the hours of blank and blank,
if you see motion outside,
turn on this light
and so it makes it seem
like somebody's turning on
their bedroom light or
turning on another light.
This is so smart.
Also they're on camera
and you can see 'em.
- And that keeps Sandra away.
- Yeah it's Sahn-dra is what she prefers.
- Sandra.
- She's insulted when
you call her Sand-ra.
- Sandra.
- I'm gonna have a whole thing for you
when you come over, man.
Then you'll be like, oh I gotta do this.
- I mean it's a novel idea.
I just--
- It's the future, man.
Everyone's gonna be
talking to their house.
And you can be like I remember in 2019,
Rhett started talking to his
house in every which way.
- In too many ways.
You can talk to it in too many ways.
Now I'm a fan of throwing
something to the television
to start watching like
watch a YouTube clip
or just start playing music.
Playing music in certain
zones in my house.
- Right.
- I do that every single day.
And I'm like, I want
this to play everywhere.
We got a party.
- But Google--
- I want this to play just downstairs
'cause Christy's upstairs takin' a nap.
- That's a great system.
- Or I want this to play only upstairs.
- Discontinue--
- My bathroom
and my bedroom.
- Chromecast Audio.
- I bought a whole stash of those
before they off the market.
I don't know why they did that.
- But what do you do now?
- That's a problem.
- What do I do?
- There's still some floating
out there you can buy.
- No they gotta be--
- If you wanna connect
to your--
- There's gotta be
a new solution.
- Do Sonos.
Not a sponsor.
- No but I'm gonna do
the outdoor speakers too.
They gotta be hard wired
to like a stereo head
of some kind.
- Go ahead--
- Then your stereo head has a Chromecast.
- Go ahead and buy a couple of
Chromecast Audios right now.
Seriously, they're still floating around.
Just buy a couple for like 25 bucks.
Just to have the option.
'Cause Google Chromecast, not audio,
doesn't work with that
system, it's a separate thing.
- Oh 'cause it doesn't have a 3.5 jack.
- I don't know, it doesn't,
but I don't know if that's the reason why.
- But that's what audio has right?
- Listen if this were a tech podcast,
people would be calling
in and we'd be telling 'em
all types of stuff.
- Well this is my secret way
of letting you know I'd
like to make Ear Biscuits
a tech podcast and two guys
who don't really know anything
about tech are gonna say
things like 3.5 jack.
- The Click and Clack of
welcoming Sandra to your house.
Remember Click and Clack?
- Yeah.
- You call in and they would tell you
about automobile stuff.
- One of 'em died.
- That's Ben and Jerry.
- No, you're talking about
Click and Clack, NPR,
they had the auto repair show
and they were like wizards
of cars.
- Oh yeah I didn't know
one of them passed away.
- Yeah.
- I also didn't know that
they invented ice creams
which I'm glad they did.
- Okay, so we're not gonna
just talk about tech.
That is what the podcast is about now,
but we promised you we'd answer questions
so next week's all about tech.
(both chuckle)
And every week after.
- Okay well let's get into
some questions but first,
let's promote some merch.
You're wearing an Ear Biscuit t-shirt.
Looks good.
- Talk about meta.
I mean I've got on Ear Biscuit t-shirt.
We're on Ear Biscuits, we're on the shirt.
Now there was a point in time
when I would have not wanted
to do this but I've embraced it.
So here we are merching it up--
- It's easier for--
- On the show.
- It's easier for you,
listener, to go out in public
with us on your shirt than it is to do it.
- That's true.
- So that's why we're inviting
you to buy it.
- I wouldn't wear this
in public, but you should.
It's a great shirt, I
wouldn't wear it just because
I don't like to be on my own shirt.
- I like to be in my shirt.
- True.
Also we got mugs that say
the same thing on 'em.
Which is the name of this podcast.
- Ear Biscuits.
- All right, Mythical.store.
Just go over there and
browse, you'll be surprised
'cause there's something
you didn't know was there.
- Now there's a lot of tech,
a lot of tech at the store.
- Tech advice.
- Yeah you can buy tech advice.
- There's a chat.
There's a chat button.
It's like chat with
someone live right now.
- And that's me talking about--
- For your tech advice.
- And my answer to
all your questions will be--
- Mythical.store.
- 3.5 jack.
I think it's millimeters,
3.5 millimeters jack.
- Yeah.
- Actually my tech name is Jack.
Link, you wanna answer some questions?
- Yeah let's get into this, man.
This is gonna be fun.
You wanna start with the creepy?
Let's start with the creepy,
I mean, we teased with it
and what if we don't get to it?
- Yeah that's a good point.
- This is a question from awhile back
and then we never got to it
and now we think it's the best question.
- Well a lot of people--
- What does that mean?
- Thumbsed it up on Facebook
so they really wanted
to hear the answer to it.
- Okay.
- Angelien Batterman.
Sometimes I meet someone
and without even speaking
to them or knowing anything about them,
I get a vibe of this person is creepy,
or this person is trustworthy
and it almost always pans out to be true.
Does this happen to
other people and if so,
what the heck are we picking up on?
- Well you know, I think that
from an evolutionary standpoint,
it's definitely advantageous
to develop the gene level skill
of a sixth sense of knowing
if someone's gonna kill you
or maim you or otherwise violate you.
So it makes sense in theory
that we would have this
inexplicable sense of creepiness
because I am saying that
creepy is correlated
to getting maimed or otherwise violated,
and then personally, I
think I experience this.
I think I do have a sense.
Like if you started showing
me, if you just went through
a line up of people and I could
make split second decisions
of creepy or like hot or both.
- Creepy or hot?
- That's the decision I make.
- It was creepy or trustworthy.
- Oh. (laughs)
- How did we get to hot?
- Oh sorry.
- Hot is usually--
- I got a little distracted.
- Hot is not sort of a sixth sense thing.
Usually it's sort of
like oh, I look at them
and find them attractive.
- In the same way that
I feel like I can look
at someone and be like, oh,
given my personal tastes,
this person is attractive.
Or whatever, but I think in the same--
- Instant?
- Instant,
I could determine
creepiness and I can do it
to the same person at the same time.
And I can say that
person is hot but creepy.
- Let's explore what we think.
- That person's hot
because they're creepy.
- We'll explore what makes someone creepy
or what you think and I think.
- Don't you feel the same?
- Oh yeah but
I don't remember what this
was, in a book or an article
or something but--
- An instant message.
- Someone was advising
people on this exact thing which is
when you have this sense
that you can't explain
that someone is creepy, you
should always act on it.
- And you should trust your instincts.
- And you should always
act on it without apology.
- So trust your--
- You should trust
your instincts.
- Regardless of who you are,
trust your instincts and don't feel like
you need to apologize,
that's a good point.
- And you shouldn't feel like you are,
don't judge yourself in that
moment where you're like,
oh is there something in me that's bad
that I'm making a
judgment about this person
that's just like, well, I don't know,
but your safety is important
and I'm not saying you gotta do something,
just getting yourself
out of that situation.
Trust your instincts and more
often than not, they're right,
but what is it that
people are picking up on?
- Well the first thing I
think about are the eyes.
And then the second thing
I think about is the mouth.
So I think about that area.
Creepiness is not necessarily
what the eyes look like
but if you've got like, if
there's a stare happening
and it's like how would you describe this?
Like what about, like
I'm looking at you now.
I'm just looking at you, right,
but and now, watch the difference.
What's happening because I'm
trying to put a name to that
as what to me is creepy.
So I'm just looking at you.
- That's pretty explicit though.
That's a facial, that's an
aggressive facial expression.
- Okay but--
- I'm just talking about--
- For the listeners--
- Somebody isn't doing anything aggress--
- For the listeners, can you just,
I think this is my answer.
- You flared your nostrils
and you raised your eyebrows.
- No I didn't.
Don't look at my nostrils.
I'm covering my nostrils and
I'm covering my eyebrows.
Am I covering my eyebrows?
- Yeah.
- All right
I'm just looking at you.
And now I'm doing that.
- Well you could be surprised,
you just sort of raised your eyes.
You opened your eyes more.
- I bugged my eyes a little bit.
- I'm not talking about picking
up on facial expressions.
- I am.
If you do, my answer is,
if you bug your--
- If someone makes a,
bugs their eyes out at you, get out!
- If your eyes,
buggy eyes compared,
not compared but paired
with a slightly open mouth,
that's dead on creepy.
- Okay well I don't disagree with that
but that just feels more obvious.
Whereas I'm talkin'
about like you've got--
- Well then I'm starting obvious.
- So think about this.
You got Ted Bundy, right, did
you watch The Ted Bundy Tapes?
- No and I don't know why anyone did.
- I watched a little bit of it and--
- Oh I'm gonna watch hours
and hours dedicated to a--
- I didn't watch hours and hours--
- Demented serial killer.
- I watched a little bit
of it, well, a lot of people--
- Love it, lot of people love it.
- Yeah.
- Hey I'm not afraid
to go against the grain.
I don't get it, man.
- And the thing that made him
such an unusual serial killer
is he was like a handsome, charming guy.
- But I bet, I haven't seen it,
but I bet he was doing that with his eyes.
- It has nothing to do
with the expressions
that he was making.
- Of course it does but, so
what do you, okay, keep going.
- I mean essentially what
you're saying is that like
if I were to go into a room
and somebody were to go,
and I just made a very angry--
- I didn't do that.
- Gorilla face.
- I just went a little like--
- Of course, yeah,
but you did a piece of an expression
but what if somebody is actually coming in
and they're doing charming things?
I believe that you probably
could still pick up
on something creepy.
If Ted Bundy has the capacity to kill you,
but yet he also has the
capacity to be charming
and to make prolonged
eye contact or whatever,
still think there's probably something
and again, I do think that
it's something visual,
aural as in audio-ish.
- That's what I was saying.
- That you're picking up on
but I don't think it's an expression.
I think it's things
more subtle like posture
or changes in tone of voice.
I'm saying--
- Okay so what posture?
- I don't know, I'm saying
that I don't know what it is.
I think it's super subtle
but I don't think it's like,
this guy, every time I look at him,
he bugs his eyes out at me.
- All right but okay, just
like a little bit of a stare,
mouth breathing, I think
inexplicable smiling
where you see teeth.
- I'm okay then, can't see my teeth.
Where are you coming
up with this criteria?
- I'm just picturing creepy people
and I'm describing them to you.
It's not rocket science.
I mean everything I've
said is creepy, right?
I mean if they're staring
and scratching, like--
- You're talking about
creepy behavior though.
I'm saying that somebody walks
in and they been instructed
to follow a protocol of
behavior that is like,
you're gonna walk into this room
and you're going to stand there
and you're going to remain stone-faced.
Two people do this, you
think one is trustworthy
and one is creepy and it isn't
because someone made a face.
It's because someone has a face.
- I think if--
- You don't understand
what I'm saying?
There's something about
their face, the structure.
- Okay, I'll go.
- The distance of the eyes.
- If the percentage of body fat contained
on the face is below 7%.
- You think some people have 7%
of their body fat on their face?
- (laughs) No.
That's not what I'm saying.
- Maybe like a large-headed baby.
(Link laughs)
- I'm saying the exact opposite, man.
If your percent body fat--
- Is 7%.
- Is 7% in the facial area or less.
If you're like gaunt.
- Just in the face.
- Yeah, I think it's like,
I was walking down the
street one time and I saw,
shoot what's the name, Walter
Scoggins, isn't that his name?
The guy from co-star with Danny
McBride in Vice Principals.
- Goggins.
- Walter Goggins.
- Isn't it Goggins?
- Great actor, hilarious guy.
He plays the harpsichordist in that new--
- HBO show.
- HBO show that you showed me.
I'm a huge fan of the guy,
but he's got a creepy vibe.
I mean he's got a creepy facial structure.
- And actually that's what
makes him so castable.
- He's got deep-set eyes,
like me, but I ain't creepy
'cause I got big, fat cheeks.
- Oh yeah you're way over 7%.
- Right I got--
- You might have 7%
of your body fat in your (laughs).
(Link chuckles)
- Lincoln and I were
sittin' in the hot tub
and of course I don't wear
my glasses in the hot tub
and I come up out of the water
and my hair's slicked back
and Lincoln's sitting
next to me like we're both
on a jet so like at point blank range,
and I come up and he's
staring at me like creepy,
and I'm like, "What?"
And he's like, "Your face is shaped
"like a upside-down diamond."
- (laughs) What?
- He's like, "You got your cheeks."
He's like, "You look so
different without glasses,"
and I was like, "Well
my hair's slicked back."
I was like, "I look like
granddaddy, don't I?"
He was like, "Your face is like a di,"
well he just said a diamond, it's like,
straight across at the top,
comes out a little bit,
comes out a big piece here
at the points of my cheeks
and then boop, boop.
How is a diamond shaped?
- Like your face upside-down.
- Boop boop boop.
- (chuckles) Apparently.
- I got a diamond face.
It's not creepy.
- No you're not creepy.
- But more, if you can see
more of the skeletal structure
of the face, then you start to get creepy.
And if you're scratching something,
then you're off the charts.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
- But you're looking for
something else I sense.
- I don't know what it
is but I'm saying that
there are these intangible things
that you are picking up on and
it's not your conscious mind
picking up on it and
that's why you shouldn't,
again, that's why you
shouldn't judge yourself
because you're picking up
on something that, again,
that you said is coming
from like a reptilian part
of your brain that's not
some conscious process.
It's just this instinct
and you should trust it.
- But it could be, I
could list a whole bunch
of other things like
unkempt, wiry eyebrows.
Like or if there's like four or five--
- Four or five eyebrows?
- That are just like
boi-oi-oi-oi-oi-oing.
- You got more than two eyebrows,
that's definitely creepy.
You mean eyebrow hairs, okay, got it.
- Like if you're inexplicably smiling
and you don't see teeth
but you're doing something
with your tongue, like
you're licking your lips
with your tongue, that's creepy.
I think the problem
actually is trustworthiness.
I'm all over creepy but
thinking somebody's trustworthy,
that's dangerous.
You're giving somebody
the benefit of the doubt.
I think you gotta be
really careful with that.
Like yeah they might have a chubby face,
chubby cheeks like me but
they might look trustworthy,
but don't trust that.
- And there is--
- Like a Ted Bundy.
- There is a tendency
to fall into prejudice here, right,
'cause people may be like well,
I don't trust this person--
- Absolutely.
- Because of the way that I
judge where they come from.
And that's obviously bad.
I'm not suggesting do that
'cause you get into some,
I'm kinda talking about
when you're in that,
when you're in a vulnerable
place and you get a vibe,
even if you get a vibe of trustworthiness,
eh, get a vibe of trustworthiness,
go into business with a person.
- No.
- And trust your instincts.
- Mm-mm.
- Start a business right
on the spot.
- No.
- Partnership.
- I'm disturbed that you were
not able to say one thing
that you think makes people,
you're like creepy blind.
- No no, because my
theory is that what makes
somebody creepy is not
something that I can articulate.
It's something that happens
in the reptilian part
of my brain and the reptilian
part of my brain cannot speak,
cannot form words, can't
even really form thoughts
in the same way, it just acts
on instinct, cause and effect
and I'm saying that there,
and I'm sure that what they've done is
they've done some study,
if we were not lazy.
If I didn't wanna roll around like a slug
and turn my lights on with my voice--
- Yeah.
- Then I'd probably Google
what makes somebody creepy
and there would be an answer,
but you know what, that's
what the internet's for,
that what Ear Biscuits is for.
- I think there was a Vsauce video,
what makes something creepy.
- Well there you go,
Vsauce has already done it.
Why are we sitting here talking about it?
- But he didn't say
why people look creepy.
That'd be a stupid video to make
'cause you'd draw a lot of,
well I think you're describing me.
- Link us to the--
- And leave that to me
on a podcast which, I'm sorry if you have
a skeletal face or that
you lick your lips,
I'm just saying to me,
you're acting creepy
and you need to stop it.
- Well link us to an
actual scientific article,
#EarBiscuits, we'll read it.
Others will too.
Here's another question from Megan Martin.
What is an experience you had as a kid
that you wish your kids
could have but can't
and then the opposite,
what is an experience your kids have--
- Oh.
- That you wish you were able
to have as kids.
(Link sighs)
- Okay do you know what you
wish our kids could experience
that they can't but we did?
- Well I think about this quite often.
And we've touched on
this in general before
but just the amount of freedom, whoa,
almost threw that off the table.
The amount of freedom
that we had growing up
which I think was partially regional
and partially generational.
- Yeah.
- Being able to go off
and do whatever we want to
and that is not something that our kids
even have the capacity to do at this point
'cause they've got,
I can track their
location on their phones.
- Summertime bike excursions.
- But the specific thing
that I was thinking about
was something we talked about
recently that we did not,
that me and you talked about
that we've never talked about publicly.
Was we were trying to remember
when we were our sons' ages,
so like maybe even younger than Locke,
so probably 14 'cause it
was 14, 15, it was like,
maybe the summer between
eighth and ninth grade.
- Mm-hmm.
- Which incidentally
is the setting for our upcoming novel--
- [Both] The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek.
- Pre-order it now, BleakCreek.com.
- It takes place in the summer of 1992.
But anyway, we had a friend Ben
who we talked about him
before, Ben Greenwood,
The Book of Mythicality
was dedicated to Ben.
He was an embodiment of
Mythicality if there ever was one.
Passed away from cancer years ago.
He was this incredibly adventurous guy
who got us into so many
things and somehow,
he talked his parents and
then we talked to our parents
into letting us travel,
they drove us in the Greenwood's Subaru
from Buies Creek to
Buckhorn Dam, which was,
it's basically the beginning
of the Cape Fear River.
The Cape Fear River's head
waters are a little bit higher
than that but this is
like there's a dam there
and you have to go over the dam.
- Right.
- And we got into a canoe,
the three of us.
- Ben's canoe, or Ben's dad's,
I don't know whose canoe it was.
- It was Ben's canoe, an
Old Town Canoe, green,
that was definitely
not a whitewater canoe,
it was like a pond canoe
but we took this canoe.
There's only two seats in a canoe
and then there's a crossbar
and we would take turns
who sat on the crossbar
and we, no supervision,
no phone, we just canoed
all of the way down
the Cape Fear River, all
the way back to our homes.
- That is a long freakin' way, I mean,
it probably, it was at
least a six hour journey.
- Yes, and--
- On the river.
- There was no--
- There are multiple rapids.
- I'm gonna check in
with you guys when you get to,
it's like Locke and Lincoln
and a friend getting
into a boat, driving them
an hour and a half away
and then just having them,
bye, hopefully you make it.
- Well we worked up to it.
I think the reason they
had the canoe was because
he could take it to the
lake on the golf course.
- We did it all the time, yeah.
- And then it's like well on the far side
of the golf course is the Cape Fear River
so we could take it there.
- We'd crossed the river
in the canoe, yeah.
- Yeah or just swim or whatever there,
and then we would take it
from there down to Erwin,
but then at some point you're like,
let's start at the
further-most point and yeah,
right below that dam like the water is
waterfalling down over that.
But yeah it's just crazy to think,
I just can't imagine doing that with
and trusting Locke and Lincoln with that.
- Well and I just always
think what does it mean?
I actually think that
my kids are, you know,
they're a lot like me,
they're naturally independent
and will do a lot of things
without any pushback.
But there are times when I'm like,
no doubt our tendency to do
things like get into a boat,
'cause I'm not saying it
wasn't, it still wasn't normal.
Our other friends weren't doing it.
- That's true.
- There were some people
who were doing it and
it was sort of accepted.
- And we wouldn't be
doing it if it weren't
for Ben initiating it.
- Right.
We needed somebody to let us
know that it could be done.
But I have to think that
our decision to do a
lot of things like that
and having it be awesome and
then having it turn out well
is one of the reasons
that we kinda lived a life
of what some people
interpret as risky behaviors
at least in terms of
taking chances on things
and trying new things.
Sometimes I worry, okay,
our kids don't have that,
they don't exercise that
level of independence
and so is that gonna
come back to haunt them?
Or is it just gonna
happen in a different way?
- Yeah I think a sense
of adventure for them
is let's go to a rock-climbing wall.
Or like when I was on this one stretch
of mountain biking with
Lincoln, I did realize that
if he fell off the bike to the left,
he would fall down, he
would careen down a cliff.
- Right.
- I was like oh,
this is cool, I bet he's scared right now.
I didn't ask him later 'cause
I realized we were going
down the wrong path and
we had to turn around
and I was just very apologetic that we had
to push our bikes back up
this really steep hill.
- Oh push huh?
- Oh but yeah I had to look on my phone
in order to figure it all out,
which we had none of that.
Of course when you're on a river,
it's easy to not get lost 'cause
there's only one direction,
there's only one river, but
you know the thing about Ben,
said he embodied Mythicality.
It's a credit to his
parents that they were,
I can't remember what we told our parents.
We're going out with Ben
on the river (mutters).
It's like I don't know how
much they really understood
but it was very clear
that Ben's parents knew
what was going on because
they're driving us there,
dropping us off, there's no question.
- My parents definitely did not know the--
- They didn't appreciate--
- It wasn't that level
of communication, it was
like I want you to tell me
where you're going.
I wanna know specifically,
I wanna see on a map,
I wanna know when you're gonna get there.
They were just like oh
the Greenwoods guy, good.
- Right but to their credit,
when I think about it, I just wonder if...
I don't know, maybe
this is a silly question
but because Ben's life
was so short and he had,
he was diagnosed with
chronic fatigue syndrome
I think in seventh grade, so like,
he no longer could even
come to public school
with us and then he was so limited that
whenever he had the energy to do things
and we were doing things
with him, it was like,
he had a little bit more
freedom to experience,
I mean he experienced so much of life
especially given the physical limitations
from which he suffered.
- Mm-hmm.
- I don't know, I take
some comfort in that
and I feel honored that we were along
for the ride, literally a
lot of times in his boat.
But maybe there was some sort of sense of
life is short, go for it.
I think that maybe his
parents had a sense of that.
- Hmm.
- That kinda led to, yeah,
we'll drop you off here
and we trust you to be,
he had a good head head
on his shoulders and he was like,
he was smart about all that type of stuff,
and we trusted him with
our lives, you know?
- The only thing I'll
say that makes me think
that I don't, I mean
maybe they acted that way
without even realizing
it but he was that way
from as far back as I can
remember when I met him
in third grade and he
told stories of Oklahoma
which is where he moved from.
All the stuff, in third grade
you're not that old, right?
You haven't lived a whole lot of life
but he had already done
so many cool things.
And so I think they would
just, they trusted him
and he was super
responsible and we just did,
again, it was a different time.
- Not that we didn't almost
die on the river many times
but that's once we got our kayaks.
- But you need that, you need that.
And that's the thing.
It's so difficult to then try to map that
onto our kids' lives because I don't,
I think about, you got Lily
driving right now, right,
she's learning to drive and
when we were 16...
Oh no I guess we were 17 at the time.
Me and you just got into a
car and drove to Indiana.
(Link chuckles)
From North Carolina.
- Well we were going to a wedding.
- Yeah but I mean--
- I mean we were meeting
your parents there.
It's just a road right,
but yeah, that's kinda,
that's a long ways for a 17 year old.
- Especially back then when
it was literally it was a map.
We had a map.
Like a paper map.
- I thought we followed, we
didn't follow your parents?
- No.
(chuckles)
- 'Cause that wouldn't be as fun.
I think we talked them
into not following them.
'Cause they drove too.
It's like we'll meet you there.
- No 'cause when we got to town
and we met my granddad, remember that?
- Yeah that's right.
- Driving along the road.
Anyway but the opposite
of the question is,
so I don't know what the answer is,
I mean there's lots of
things that I'd like my kids
to be able to experience but I'm also glad
that they're not doing
anything as risky as we did
so it's really tough to answer
but what do they get to do
that we kinda wish that we got to do?
- Well the first things
that comes to my mind is
our kids come to the studio
and they're in videos
and stuff, I mean I think we
would be eating it up if--
- That's true.
- If we had access, I mean we're still,
that's why we're so, we're
living our childhood dreams
that we couldn't even articulate.
So it's like, man,
your dad worked at the law school
and they just happened to
have this setup with two VCRs
and you thought well
that was our opportunity
to edit video for the first time
but that was like heaven.
It was like I'm going and I got Dad's key
and I'm going into the two VCR room.
- Yeah.
- I mean it's like
think about if it wasn't
two VCRs but it was this.
Like hey, I can be on my
dad's show or something.
We're filming some stuff,
we film stuff with Shando all the time.
Like gettin' them into it
because they're so stinking cute
and the way that they play
off of each other is hilarious
because they're so different.
- Well and we did a similar thing
with Locke and Lincoln back,
was it The Mythical Show?
- Yeah The Mythical Show.
- They came in
and did a segment.
- Yeah it was like--
- When they were cute.
(Link chuckles)
- But they don't--
- But they don't wanna
be a part of it now.
- It's not like they're living a dream,
it's just like they get a kick out of it.
Lily actually said, "You
know what, I'd like to be
"in a video again."
She still thinks it's kinda--
- Oh yeah 'cause she did
some stuff last year.
- Yeah.
She's gonna come in next week
and watch us film some stuff.
She's excited about it.
I'm glad that they do feel that way
but our minds would have been blown, man,
if it was like, I don't know,
maybe we wouldn't have cared.
It's like we would have grown up,
if our dads were like,
worked at the public access
television studio or something,
that's kinda what the
equivalent would have been.
- The first thing that came to my mind was
the stuff that our kids get to do.
And this is partly because of our jobs
and partly because of where we live
but also, this is a much more
travel-oriented generation.
It's much more, people fly a lot more,
people go a lot further.
I think about the vacations
that we've been on
with our family, our kids
have been to Australia,
our kids have been to Europe
and Locke's been to Africa.
You're gonna be--
- Lily went to China.
- She went to China--
- With a friend of hers.
- And you're gonna be in
that part of the country,
part of the world again.
And our kids get to eat
all this amazing food
when amazing food for me was Shoney's.
- Yeah you're talking
about amazing food in LA.
- Yeah well and around the world too.
I don't know, I feel--
- Yeah it would have
been nice to be spoiled
like our kids have is
basically what you're saying.
- I'm of two minds about this though
because I kinda think that
the fact that really up until
I graduated college,
Shoney's was still (clicks tongue),
that was as good as it got for
me, you know what I'm saying?
I think that I'm able to, I
think you adjust pretty quickly
but I think I'm able
to kind of appreciate,
we traveled a little bit,
we would go to Georgia
to see family but--
- Remember that time
that my mom took me and me to Carowinds?
- Yeah, I'll never forget
it because those kinds
of things were so, they were
anomalies in our experience.
It was just going to an
amusement park near Charlotte.
- Pretty awesome.
- Yeah.
- Would have blown our minds.
- You wanna go to Carowinds?
Is that what you're asking?
- Would have blown our minds
to go to Six Flags.
It wouldn't have been that much different.
- Yeah so I don't know, in one sense,
I think what I'm saying is
there's things that come
to mind that I would have liked to do
and I'd like them to
do but at the same time
I'm kinda glad that I had the life I had
and they have the life they have.
- Yeah, don't have the power to change it
so let's just reconcile it.
- Yeah just accept it.
- Jonathan Garlinghouse, if you
guys were to face each other
in a quote, dad sports triathlon,
and in parentheses he
put darts, pool, bowling.
Is this a thing or did he make that up?
Is a dad sports triathlon
a thing and it consists
of darts, pool, and bowling?
His question is, what
strengths would you bring to it
and who would win overall?
Well I mean I am not...
I'm trying as hard as I can
when I throw darts on the show.
- Yep.
- I mean I'm just,
I just got no chance, man.
And we're so close to that
board and I'm horrible at it.
- But I don't think your
weakness is the targeting.
- It kinda is.
- I think your weakness is
the guessing.
Are you historically that
far from your guesses?
- Yeah, I mean if you were to super impose
like an actual dart board and
the amount of fidelity there,
I'm telling you right now--
- Well somebody should do that.
- I would be horrible at it.
- But we have, well--
- Pool, not great at that.
You're not good at, so you
would beat me at darts.
- But we've done pool and
bowling on, well okay,
if we're judging this by performance
on Good Mythical Morning, I
actually think historically,
you would win, we played pool one time
and you were better at it than me.
I don't think I'm that
bad of a pool player
but you beat me on that day.
And then bowling, when we
did the flame bowling--
- I was better.
- At least in the edit,
you got more of the strikes.
(Link chuckles)
- No if we're bowling
one game of bowling...
Is it called a round?
I don't know, a set?
I don't know what it's called.
A frame.
I would, I think I'd beat
you, but if we went two,
my fingers give out.
- But here's the thing though is that
if you isolate this down
to pure, pure competition
and entertainment value,
it's not being filmed.
- Mm-hmm.
- And it's just simply,
I kinda go into a very specific
mode in those scenarios.
- Yeah, which sends me into another mode
so your mode is--
- I get very competitive.
- I have to win, my--
- I would be tough to beat
if it was just about winning.
- Yeah and it sends me
into my mode which is
why am I doing this again?
(Rhett laughs)
I'm searching for a motivation.
Yeah I'm just like, I really don't,
even in winning, I'm looking around like
for some sort of an instruction manual.
- When you win.
- Yeah I just don't really--
- Well the winning is the reward.
- I don't really care that much.
- It's the winning, that's it.
- I do think that--
- It's not the champagne
that comes afterwards.
- I might could really
work up some gumption
and I think I could beat you at bowling.
I think that would be a good competition.
- It'd definitely be close.
- I think like Frisbee golf,
I think that would be pretty even.
I like to think I'm pretty
good with a Frisbee.
- Yeah, yeah.
We did that, we used
to do that in college.
- But I'd blow you away at napping.
- Is that a dad, that's a dad thing?
- I'm just saying, yeah, dad's gonna sit,
hit the couch and who's
gonna go out first?
I could definitely blow you
out of the water at napping.
- I can't nap competitively.
That's a given.
- I mean after we had that
meeting, before we came in here--
- You snored within 30 seconds.
- Well yeah I laid down on the couch,
I was like we got a meeting in 12 minutes.
I'm gonna take a 12 minute nap
and Jade was sittin' on my
lap and I even had to pee
and I had to move Jade
because she was on my bladder.
I had to pee, I had a
dog sleeping on top of me
'cause she's constantly sleeping.
And I know I fell asleep
because I did that jerk thing.
- You're such a jerk.
- I did the jerk.
I actually looked it up, it's
called a hypnagogic jerk.
- Yeah.
- You said I was snoring, is that--
- No exaggeration within a
minute there was a (snorts),
there was like a--
- That was when I jerked.
- Oh yeah (chuckles), okay.
- Also called a hypnic
jerk or sleep starts.
- Sleep starts?
- Sleep starts,
like I think that's short for startle.
- Okay.
Yeah I've had that happen
but in a 12 minute--
- That's why I'm a little
grumpy right now 'cause--
- A 12 minute--
- A 12 minute nap--
- It's supposed to help.
- Well it should have been,
I think it should have been
20 minutes is a power nap,
right, not 12 minutes.
- But a 12 minute nap would not,
even under the best
circumstances I wouldn't go
to sleep in 12 minutes.
It would just be I'm resting my eyes.
I'm really trying to go to sleep.
- But I literally went to sleep in--
- A minute.
- (chuckles) Again so it's
like I'm saying let's put that
in there.
- But that's not part
of the triathlon, it's just
darts, pool, and bowling.
- We rapped about, in
that Thoughtful Guy thing,
we talked about the hypnagogic jerk.
And it's like, I wonder if
it's a defense mechanism
for something, like,
sleepin' on a cliff or just top bunking.
And they don't know why it happens but--
- It's the same reason
you find people creepy.
- The prevailing theory
if you're interested is
that from a evolutionary,
primal version of us,
if you're a primate sleeping in a tree,
like if you fall asleep then you're like,
the relaxation of your muscles
then triggers a reflex to--
- Grab.
- To grab so you don't
fall out of the tree.
- I thought it was so you
don't fall out of the womb
as a baby.
- (chuckles) Fall out of the womb.
- That can happen.
- That's not up to you,
that's up to the womb.
- Oh.
- So I think we were right
about the top bunking thing.
Or like sleeping on a
cliff, sleeping in a tree.
It's when that jerk happens.
- That makes sense to me.
- So I'm winning at that too so I'm--
- Well I could add golf to
the dad thing and then I win.
I mean if we're adding
things that we're good at,
then we can just add ad nauseum.
- Getting nauseated, I'd win at that.
(Rhett sputters)
- How 'bout another question?
One last question before
the Rec In Effect.
- Okay.
- This is from Austin Kampen.
Touches on something
we've talked about before
but this is a different analysis of it.
- Where does it touch it?
- If it was confirmed that
we were in the matrix
or some equivalent simulation
which of course we are,
and there--
- Is that your words
or his?
- This is Austin.
He's saying all of this.
- Oh.
- And there was a way
out, would you take it?
You'd be leaving your family,
friends, and life behind
for an unknown real world,
would it be worth it?
So obviously we talked, in fact,
we made a valiant attempt
to escape the simulation.
- Right, we held hands.
- On this very show.
- [Together] We two
guys are Link and Rhett
and we know we are in a
simulation and we want out!
- Now!
- It did not work unless we
escaped into a simulation
that was exactly the
same as the one we left.
- 'Cause you were in a--
- 'Cause there's no way
to prove that we didn't.
- So you kinda answered the
question that if you wanted
to escape, you were having some alone time
and you were thinking about if you were,
if you could break out, would
you, and you said out loud--
- I was in the hot tub and I said,
"I know this is a simulation.
"Let me out now," or something.
- And I want out.
'Cause I thought that
maybe that was the key
was just to acknowledge it.
- But then we tried it as
buddies, holding hands.
- Doesn't work as buddies.
But the thing I did consider--
- That's your answer.
But your answer at the
time was you would do it.
You seemed to just drag me along for the--
- No and okay here's what I'll say.
My knee-jerk--
- Your hypnagogic jerk--
- My hypnagogic jerk answer
to this question is that by default,
I would get out of the
simulation because it would be
moving towards truth, right,
so and now I'm gonna think
about it on a second level
and maybe take it back but I'm
saying my knee-jerk reaction
to it is oh, this is a simulation?
- Yeah.
- But yet there's a truth
beyond that that you
can actually ascend to.
Yes I'm gonna go there regardless
of what's on the other side.
- And you say ascend but
it may be descend to.
- Yeah, it could be.
- I think that's the point.
- Yeah.
But Austin has got me
thinking differently about it
because now all of a sudden
what he's saying is that,
okay--
- Austin had to remind you
that you have a family. (chuckles)
- No it's like okay,
so obviously our family
but you've got your dog
Jade is in the room with us
in Jenna's lap over there.
- Can I see the--
- So.
- Can I see the dog?
- And I don't have any proof of this
but you seem to be as
attached to Jade as you are
to any human that you are
in a relationship with.
Now, for a moment consider
that Jade is not real,
she is only,
she's just the result of
some clever programming.
But by definition, excising
yourself from the simulation
would mean that you could no longer be
in a relationship with her.
- Am I doing it?
I mean I'm...
Yeah I got too much to
lose, man, look at me.
I got it goin' on.
I mean you painted a
simple picture for me.
- But it's not real.
It's not real.
- Neither am I.
- No, no, that's exactly, no.
You are real and you can get out, now,
maybe Jade is an avatar of
another dog that you can make
a connection with outside
of the simulation.
Maybe your wife is an
avatar of another individual
that you can make a
connection with outside
of the simulation.
I don't know if the
simulation exists just for you
or if we're all avatars in a simulation,
you don't know that until you
get out of the simulation.
- Why would the...
Why would it be, it seems easier for me
to believe that it would be worse
outside of the simulation because,
I'm biased because I got
a #blessedlife, okay?
And it's, but it seems
cruel that it's all fake,
it's all a simulation so
it seems like that cruelty
that set it up--
- It seems cruel?
Why does it seem cruel?
- Because it's not real.
- You're #blessed, man.
- I know but I'm just saying on a...
But it's a farce, it's a lie.
It's a lie that's a favor I guess to me.
- Maybe it is.
Maybe it's just an
experiment, I don't know.
But now if I knew definitively,
like this is the thing is that--
- How could it be better,
again, it's like, I'm--
- The people in the
matrix had, they came out
of the matrix and saw the real world
and then made decisions to stay
'cause they could come back, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- But I'm just saying
this is like an all or nothing deal,
if you leave you can't get back
and you don't know
what's on the other side.
For me, the unknown and the
fact that it is a simulation
and you can get out of it,
the curiosity is too high.
And then I would just
justify it, I would be like,
of course I love my family.
Of course I love my life.
But if they are ultimately just a program,
then I'm not really and I'm
just inside this simulation,
I'm not really, I'm losing an idea.
I'm not losing actual beings.
- Again this is like the robot
relationship conversation.
I thought we became convinced that yes,
we could have what would experientially be
a viable relationship with a robot
and we were cool with that.
- But that's self-aware self-deception.
- So just extend that to
an entire family of robots
that you're, it's like
surprise, your family is robots.
- I just think the fact that you don't,
that there's something
that you could know,
that there's something on
the outside that is too much.
With the robots, I know
what the alternative is
and I can slip into it at any time.
I can cease to, I can be
like, this relationship,
it's just with a robot
or I can enter into it
and make myself believe it.
- But that makes it sound like,
given the way you describe it, like okay,
you would go to Mars.
You would leave your family
to discover the next frontier.
- No because my family
is real in that scenario.
I'm leaving people who have the capacity,
not only is it what I feel,
but they also have the capacity to grieve.
- But in the simulation, they do,
they would grieve.
- Yeah but if a robot
was about to kill my dog,
I'd kill the robot.
Do you know what I'm saying?
- I don't know how that applies.
Someone's not about to,
your family member's
not about to kill you.
- I have a bias towards biological life.
Sue me.
- I have a bias towards
my own current happiness.
(Rhett laughs)
- Okay, I mean that's cool, man.
I don't know what happens to
me when I leave the simulation.
One day I'll figure it out.
I don't know if my body just drops.
- You're livin' a good life, man.
- And I just die.
- The chances of,
again, there's a lot of people
who are livin' difficult lives.
I mean we are in a
percentage of people on Earth
who are living...
We don't deserve how good we've got it.
- But you're assuming that--
- The chances that it's better
than what we've got (scoffs)--
- But you're assuming--
- Are nil, man.
- That my primary motivation
is increased comfort.
I mean I do want to speak
to my home as a slug.
- I know, so--
- That is true.
- Right.
- But my primary motivation
for moving into the next
thing is not increased comfort
as much as it's increased discovery.
- I think your primary
motive is seeming like
you could take a provocative stance.
- No, no.
See, 'cause if you were
to adopt my opinion,
that would be true about you
but that's not true about me.
I want Sandra to come over because I want
to discover what it
would be like for Sandra
to have a special soundtrack
with flashing lights.
- Give me an example of
when you have sacrificed
present comfort for future discovery,
for potential discovery?
- Potential discovery?
It happens all the time.
Like tasting the new Carl's Jr. burger.
- What?
You're denying yourself,
what are you denying?
What are you giving up?
- You don't know how
it's gonna go down, man.
- A lame example.
- Okay.
- Rack your brain.
- Hot chicken.
(laughs)
It's not comfortable.
I wanted the hottest one
to see what it was like.
I didn't think it was gonna be good.
- But if Instagram didn't
exist, you would have done it?
- I did it the other
day with no Instagram.
- Okay that's true.
- No but also I don't--
- That's not much
of a sacrifice.
- Hold on but no,
I think our whole career though.
I don't think that it's
been primarily motivated
by more comfort.
- No.
That's true.
- But any type of, you
and the Spartan race.
It wasn't about comfort.
It was about self-discovery, man.
I think that's human nature.
If you're like listen, I can't promise you
what it's gonna be like
when you go into this room.
It could be really bad or
it could really be good,
the thing is is if you go into this room,
the thing I can promise is
it will be mind-blowing.
You're not gonna go in that room?
I'm gonna go into that room.
- But you can never
come back from the room.
- Yeah.
- That's the thing.
- I don't care, I'm going in, man.
- That's the problem.
- I'm going in.
- The problem is coming back.
I don't think we've been faced with that.
The examples that you've
given are not like that,
like it's a valve, you can't go back.
- Tattoo?
(Link scoffs)
Getting a tattoo?
- You gotta keep thinking, man.
I'm not convinced that you would do it.
- I'm just saying as a principle.
- Priors.
- No,
when I was in the hot
tub, I was really trying
to get out and I was
really trying to get out
when we were here.
(chuckles)
Okay.
- I wasn't.
That's why I had so much fun trying.
- Let us know what you
would do, #EarBiscuits.
But I do wanna leave you
with a Rec In Effect.
- Oh yeah, give me a
rec, man, it's your turn.
♪ Check baby check ♪
- I tend to recommend shows I've noticed.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna recommend another show.
For those of you who like weird,
it's weird and it's not for everybody
and that's why I like it.
The second season just came
back on Netflix, The OA.
Did you ever watch that?
- No I didn't.
- Anybody else in here watch that?
- It's a sci-fi situation?
- Yeah and I'm not gonna...
Basically what the show's about,
by telling you what the
show's about is basically
sort of like the season one spoiler
so I'm not gonna do that.
It just, 'cause once you
figure out what's going on,
so there's a little bit
of a mystery aspect.
It's just super weird.
- So if you like weird sci-fi.
- Yeah.
- Is it like Black Mirror?
- It has Black Mirror-ish elements in that
they're kind of delving in
and asking some philosophical questions
of what if this could happen,
what if this were true
and it is a concept that
people have explored
in philosophy and it's
kind of just exploring
what it would be like and then--
- Are there any jolly laughs?
- It is not funny at all.
- Well you gotta have
a little comic relief.
- It would be nice if it was
funny, it's not funny at all.
- Is the writing good, is the acting good?
Is it more about--
- Yes.
The writing and acting is good.
- Is there any stars
that I would recognize?
- You would recognize the antagonist
but I don't know what he's from
but you would recognize him.
- Okay.
- And then the second season,
we just started watching
that, Jessie and I,
it's one of the shows
that we enjoy together,
we started watching that
and it was just like,
'cause I was thinking
where are they gonna go?
Where are they gonna go from here?
- Is it rated R?
Is it for the kids?
- Mm, it's not bad.
I think kids could watch it.
- Can I start with season two?
- No, definitely not.
- Okay.
- And honestly--
- OA!
- I don't know if you'd like it.
'Cause it's just one of
those things that it's like,
it's weird, in fact, and
my good friends Lance
and Lacey who are kind of
the authority on weird,
without being prompted, they just texted
in the text thread that
they have with me and Jessie
and they were like,
"You guys watch The OA?
"Super weird, I think you'd
like it," and we were like,
"Oh we love it.
"We watch it together."
- But you don't think I would like it.
- Well--
- I got limited screen time.
I'm still trying to catch up on
Game of Thrones.
- The thing I have observed
about the way that you
analyze television shows
and movies is you have a
difficult time enjoying things
that don't have likable characters.
And this is not,
I don't find the main
character particularly likable
and I don't find anybody very likable.
- I liked--
- I like the story.
- I like Handmaid's Tale but
I didn't like House of Cards
at the beginning.
But I watched--
- You also didn't like that,
what's that show on
Showtime, or maybe it's HBO
that's about the rich family
that's supposed to be like--
- Oh The Descendants?
- It's supposed to be like
Rupert Murdoch's family.
- [Both] Succession.
- You didn't like that when
you started watching it
'cause you were like I
don't like any of the people
and I'm like that's why I like it,
because I don't like any of the people.
- Yeah.
- So if you don't--
- It's so harsh.
- If you like to watch shows
where everyone is unlikeable,
(chuckles) you'll love The OA.
- Really, okay.
- But it's not like that.
It's not like the main character,
the protagonist is not a
jerk and you don't hate them
and they're not morally
corrupt, it's just--
- I loved House back in the day.
- I don't think you'd--
- He was so unlikable,
he was likable.
And that was the device.
- There you go, okay, maybe there's hope.
- It's different.
All right.
- I'm gonna tell my house
to play the next episode of OA for me.
See how it responds.
- House, whenever I walk up
to you and enter your front,
start playing The OA on every screen.
- What if I asked the house to play House?
It might just implode.
- Well it's probably smarter than that.
Like--
- Play myself?
What?
Break down. (laughs)
(Link makes buzzing sound)
You want your whole house to
collapse, ask it to play House.
- Yeah, I mean I ain't doing that.
(Rhett chuckles)
- #EarBiscuits, talk to us.
Keep listening, don't give up on us.
- Yeah.
It'll get better.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)